il y a 400000 ans un nouvel homme voit
le jour il est le premier représentant
d'une famille extraordinaire celle des
Homo sapiens la nôtre
ses enfants ont traversent les mers et
les montagnes s'adaptent à tous les
climats
plusieurs fois ils perdent tout mais
trouve toujours le moyen de survivre et
d'aller au-delà de leur limite
[Musique]
ils apprivoisent les plantes les animaux
ils construisent des villages et change
les paysages l'homme devient la plus
puissante créature du monde animal
il se lance à la conquête de
l'imaginaire découvre l'art la magie et
les rêves
nous sommes leurs enfants
leur savoir s'est transmis sur plus de
50 000 générations pour arriver jusqu'à
nous
quelle est leur véritable histoire
[Musique]
comment ont-ils peuplé la Terre
comment ont-ils fait pour que nous
soyons là aujourd'hui
voici l'histoire de la fabuleuse
ascension de notre grande famille
celle des Homo sapiens
[Musique]
comment débute cette histoire comment
notre espèce est à la parue d'où
vient-elle
rappelez-vous il y a 8 millions d'années
la planète se refroidissent soudainement
l'eau est aspirée par l'épaule une
immense calotte de glace se forme en
Europe et en Asie au nord la vie
commence à s'acclimater au froid
sous les tropiques la nature a soif
cherche désespérément à plus d'humidité
[Musique]
en Afrique les grands singes voient
leurs forêt disparaître deux d'entre eux
Aurora et Toumaï s'adaptent à la savane
et invente une nouvelle façon de se
déplacer il se mette debout
il disparaissent il y a 4 millions
d'années en donnant naissance à de
nouvelles espèces mieux adaptées les
australopithèques
Lucie s'est congénère se met en marche
il survivent en se nourrissant de
végétaux de plus en plus dur et coriace
puis tombe à leur tour victime de leur
fragilité
et des prédateurs
[Musique]
alors arrive Homo habilis l'homme habile
le premier véritable représentant du
genre humain il invente l'outil comment
on s'agir sur le monde et à le parcourir
son évolution le change en Homo erectus
l'homme dressé le découvreur du feu le
pouvoir de l'homme fait un bon immense
dans le règne animal
erectus se lance à la conquête du monde
il sort d'Afrique entre en Asie et en
Europe
quelques dizaines de milliers d'hommes
et de femmes dispersés en petits groupes
qui préparent sans le savoir l'arrivée
de notre espèce
[Musique]
imaginez
nous sommes il y a 400 000 ans au cœur
du continent africain
marche parfois jusqu'à 50 km par jour
pour survivre
il chasse de petits animaux que des
baies et des racines pour lui et les
siens
parfois il meurt sur le chemin au mieux
il vit jusqu'à 25 ou 30 ans
la disparition d'un délai est toujours
vécue comme une souffrance
mais erectus ne sait rien du mystère de
la mort
où est parti le souffle pourquoi ne
bouge-t-il plus
toujours derrière eux le danger qui
menace
il faut marcher mourir c'est la loi
[Musique]
la dépouille est abandonnée aux animaux
on se rappellera encore quelques temps
de l'être aimé puis le souvenir
s'évanouir
quand erectus s'installe pour la nuit il
commence par construire des abris pour
se protéger puis il fait un feu pour
écarter les prédateurs
il s'est aussi faire toutes sortes
d'outils mais tout cela ne compte pas
pour la femme qui porte l'enfant voilà
des jours qu'elle ne mange que des
racines la femme a besoin de force pour
celui qui bouge en elle
ne veut plus dire
qu'il n'a pas réussi à trouver le gibier
mais c'est très bien que ces racines
sont amères on est calme pas la fin
mais ce n'est pas une raison pour le lui
faire remarquer
erectus est curieux et toujours à
l'affût de la moindre nouveauté
le chef a déjà entendu ce bruit mais
aujourd'hui ce son qui résonne lui plaît
ça ne résonne plus
c'est
ça y est
si on colle son oreille c'est beaucoup
mieux
[Applaudissements]
au moins rectus et chasseur au petit
matin le chef et son frère sont partis
sur les traces prometteuses d'une qui
marche sur deux pattes
mais la trouver ne suffit pas à la
course elle est beaucoup trop rapide
alors on organise un stratagème
chacun son rôle un qui rabat l'autre qui
attend
des termites jaunes les jaunes lui il ne
peut pas résister
le chef connaît bien le caractère de
celle qui marche sur deux pattes avec
ses œufs c'est une manière
elle les connaît tous un par un et s'il
en manque ne serait-ce qu'un seul c'est
la crise
[Musique]
la chasse est lancée le piège va se
refermer sur l'animal
et que fait le frère
si elle le rattrape c'est la mort c'est
pas de son coupon comme des silex
la peau comme une pointe de lance
le frère trouve toujours un moyen pour
tout gâcher on ne peut pas lui faire
confiance
mais l'animal ne peut plus fuir
c'est une bonne chose
ce jour est un bon jour pour la rictus
[Musique]
erectus commence par manger les tomates
riches en végétaux
puis il découpe l'animal pour le
transporter dans ses campements
les images de la capture sont encore
dans la tête du chef
la bête est tombée dans le trou et tout
est devenu facile il y en a une idée
mais les mouches piquent et l'empêche de
réfléchir
le corps d'erectus est de moins en moins
évolué sa peau nu est constamment
soumise aux agressions des insectes
surtout les endroits sensibles
à cet endroit le frère n'est pas piqué
par les mouches
c'est la peau de l'animal
avec la peau les mouches ne piquent plus
c'est peut-être comme cela qui rectus a
inventé la vie
le partage de l'avion des soumis à la
place que chacun occupe dans la
hiérarchie du groupe les chasseurs sont
servis les premiers puis viennent les
femelles préférée auquel on réserve un
morceau de choix
celle qui porte l'enfant a maintenant
son gibier et erectus et conforté dans
sa fierté de chef et de protecteur
mais le pouvoir n'est jamais acquis on
tourne le dos et quelqu'un est prêt à
vous prendre la place
[Musique]
ça peut
il a oublié sa peau
[Musique]
c'est ça c'est sa place et il est le
chef il y a des choses qu'on ne partage
pas
comme la femme qui porte l'enfant comme
la souffrance ou l'espoir
[Musique]
de toutes les images qui remplissent sa
tête et sorties celles d'un trou le chef
a décidé d'en creuser un là où les
animaux viennent boire pour qu'ils
tombent dedans comme celle de pattes
mais de creuser la boue à donner une
nouvelle apparence à son corps le chef
est surpris il ne reconnaît plus son
frère
[Rires]
le rire est certainement apparu à cette
époque un comportement qui aura de
l'avenir
peut-être les premières rires de
l'humanité mais aussi la découverte du
beau grâce à une trouvaille d'importance
pierre différente des autres
il la trouve belle alors la pierre
devient autre chose une parure qui fait
plaisir à regarder
qu'est-ce que ça donne
il n'est pas beau comme ça
c'est son signe le signe du chef
le chef voudrait que celle qui porte
l'enfant regarde la pierre
et ce n'est pas le moment la douleur est
montée dans le ventre de la femme la
femme peut être seule pour ce moment où
l'enfant tombera de son ventre
elle sait ce qu'elle doit faire sans
l'avoir appris
[Musique]
chef est plein d'espoir le piège la peau
qui protège la pierre
mais l'enfant
va-t-il arriver
une fois sur deux il vient sans le
souffle comme ce qui tombe sur le chemin
parfois même les douleurs se terminent
par la mort de la femme
la vie viendra-t-elle
[Musique]
il est vivant
c'est une petite fille elle a une drôle
de tête avec son front tout droit et sa
peau sans poil elle a l'air si fragile
et vulnérable
[Musique]
le chef ne veut pas que le froid prenne
son souffle
lycée maintenant sa peau n'est plus pour
lui sa peau et pour l'enfant
[Musique]
sans le savoir ils viennent de donner
naissance à une nouvelle espèce d'homme
une espèce qui va bientôt les remplacer
au mot rectus sont peut-être qu'il a
fait son temps et que l'avenir est là
entre ses bras
[Musique]
il va changer la vie des hommes et
conquérir le monde
l'évolution des rectus ont sapiens s'est
faite sur des centaines de générations
petit à petit son corps devient plus
élancé son front se redresse son cerveau
devient plus vaste plus complexe
sapiens sort d'Afrique explore le
Moyen-Orient il commence à s'habiller
développe son sens esthétique et ses
outils sa pensée et son imagination vont
faire de lui un autre homme
nous sommes à moins 100000 ans
[Musique]
les orages de chaleur sont les pires ils
tuent à chacun de leur passage
[Musique]
mais d'où vient cette lumière qui
aveugle qui crache cette colère qui fait
trembler au crâne
un d'entre nous va trouver une réponse
aux grandes mystères de la mort
[Musique]
s'appelle nécalogène
depuis qu'il s'est chassé n'est qu'à
protège sa mère et sa petite sœur
[Musique]
le clan avait marché depuis la venue du
jour le vent était levé soudainement et
le ciel s'était mis à cracher du feu
le chef avait cherché un refuge mais
rien
et non c'était serré les uns contre les
autres en attendant que passe la fureur
de la nature
la sœur de Neka a eu peur elle est
partie tout d'un coup sans prévenir sa
mère l'a suivi pour la protéger
c'est à ce moment que la tragédie est
entrée dans la vie de Neka
de la foudre tombée sur la mer une bête
à corne est apparue
mais qu'elle l'a vu l'animal est parti
en laissant les corps de sa sœur et de
la mer sur le sol
[Musique]
n'avait pas su les protéger il s'en
voulait il fallait qu'elle bouge qu'elle
se remette debout
[Musique]
très vite notre chef a compris que le
souffle les avait quittés mais n'est
qu'à ne voulait pas croire il refusait
d'entendre et de voir ce que tous
voyaient
elles étaient mortes il n'y avait rien à
faire et le chef voulait partir au plus
vite mais n'est qu'à vous les restez là
il voulait attendre qu'elle se réveille
comme si c'était possible
le chef ne comprenait pas mais il ne
pouvait pas abandonner necka alors on
s'est arrêté là au début c'était juste
pour une nuit
[Musique]
sapiens c'est nomade avec ses pots il
fait maintenant des abris
son langage ses perfectionné il a des
mots pour parler des choses abstraites
comme du temps derrière soi et du devant
son cerveau a plus de mémoire il est
capable de plus d'associations son
imagination s'en trouve augmentée et il
est probable que ses rêves deviennent
plus impressionnants dans son sommeil
sapiens croit qu'il voyage dans un autre
monde un monde parallèle situé derrière
les yeux
le clan dormait encore quand une bête à
grande corne est venue boire à la
rivière
le corps d'un animal de cette taille
c'était de la viande pour tout le clan
pour Neka cela ne faisait aucun doute
c'était la même bête à corne celle qui
était venue la veille dans la grande
lumière
cette fois là le chef n'a pas été trop
mal à droite
elle était blessée à mort le chef était
fier le clan aurait des semaines de
nourriture grâce à lui mais ce n'est pas
la viande qui occupait les pensées de
Neka dans le souffle de l'animal qui
s'enfuyait il entendait gémir la voix de
sa sœur
au moment où la bête perdait la vie
l'inexplicable est arrivé
[Musique]
le souffle de l'animal avait disparu et
celui de sa sœur était revenu
comment était-ce possible
Naoki
respirer
elle retrouvait la vie non
[Musique]
c'est ainsi que Naoki est revenu parmi
nous et tout le monde se réjouit mais
NECA était préoccupé il voulait
comprendre ce qui s'était passé
[Musique]
l'animal avait-il donné son souffle à sa
sœur
la mort de l'animal avait-elle permis de
redonner la vie à Naoki c'était un grand
mystère
le chef aurait voulu qu'on le félicite
pour sa prise mais tout le clan était
fasciné par le miracle de Neka
[Musique]
avait un nouvel espoir
peut-être restait-il dans la peau de la
bête un peu du souffle de l'animal pour
le donner à sa mère
au début tout le monde se dit que NECA
avait perdu la raison
mais il suivait une idée fixe la bête à
corne pouvait redonner vie à sa mère
[Musique]
on espérait aussi que la mer reviendrait
mais le comportement de Neka nous
échappait il ne mangeait pas il restait
près du corps en attendant un signe
le signe est venu du ciel comme toujours
les charognards sont arrivés pour
prendre le cadavre
refusé cela aussi si les vautours
prenaient la chair de sa mère aucun
souffle ne pourrait y revenir
c'est peut-être ce jour-là comment ça
bien ça a inventer la première sépulture
[Musique]
protéger le corps du défunt probablement
aussi pour se protéger de la vision de
ce corps qui pourrit car même sans les
vautours le corps disparaissait petit à
petit
[Musique]
le chef voulait que mange et il sait
personnellement déplacé pour lui offrir
un morceau de choix ce qu'il ne fait
jamais en fait il voulait que lui donne
le secret de sa magie
il voulait comprendre comment on est cas
avait redonné vie à Naoki
mais il n'était pas au bout de ses
surprises
lui disait que sa mère vivait dans un
autre monde et qu'elle devait manger
mais le jeune a donné sa viande pour la
mer
s'en était trop elle n'avait plus besoin
de nourriture elle était morte
ce monde certains d'entre nous ont
commencé à y croire
c'était le monde dans lequel on allait
en dormant
on y croisait nos morts
c'était le pays des songes
quelques jours plus tard trois d'entre
nous ont décidé de quitter le clan nous
étions nombreux et les conflits éclatés
trop souvent
il voulait trouver un autre clan et un
autre chef
celui-là il ne le supportait plus
[Musique]
avant de partir il voulait entendre
encore né qu'à raconter les images qu'il
voyait derrière ses yeux
[Musique]
il voulait écouter le récit
extraordinaire de la mère de Neka pour
ne pas l'oublier pour l'emporter avec
eux
[Musique]
celui où les morts allaient quand le
souffle l'équité
il voyait sa mère avec la bête ou grande
corne et sa mère le regardait comme pour
lui dire que tout allait bien qu'elle
n'avait plus faim qu'elle n'avait plus
froid
[Musique]
derrière ses yeux il y avait une lueur
qui disait que la vie continuait
ailleurs
une vie après la mort
et cela change tout
ces croyances
sont sans toutes les prémices de la
pensée religieuse une extraordinaire
composition de l'imaginaire qui dotera
sapiens d'une force phénoménale la foi
l'idée d'éternité va se répandre chez
tous les peuples et apaiser l'angoisse
de la mort l'homme peut maintenant
s'engager au-delà des limites de sa
propre existence
le temps des croyances chamaniques est
arrivé le monde des esprits côtoie
maintenant celui des vivants nous sommes
entre -100 000 et -50 000 ans sapiens
explore presque tous les territoires de
la planète certains vont vers l'Asie
d'autres vers l'Europe
pourquoi ce risque-t-il dans un monde
inconnu
suivit-il les migrations du gibier les
signes de la nature
beaucoup croit au pouvoir du soleil et
de la lune
il y a 50 000 ans le premier groupe
d'Homo sapiens arrive au sud de l'Europe
ce clan vous sa vie au soleil ça
disparition en plein jour les terrifies
[Musique]
une femme entre en transe pour lutter
contre les dévoreurs de lumière
[Musique]
il revient le soleil revient
la femme qui les Guille des chamans elle
s'appelle nata et elle est née de trois
sœurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour Nathan le soleil est sombrit est un
mauvais signe les soleils doivent être
forts pour que vive le clan il faut les
suivre derrière les montagnes jusque
dans le pays où ils vont tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il devrait renoncer
pourtant la foi les portes et il
n'hésite pas à s'engager dans le voyage
le plus périlleux qu'ils aient jamais
fait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
découvre la terre blanche pour la
première fois mais leurs pieds brûlent
sur les choses qui prend la forme de
tout ce qui la touche
alors pour se protéger du froid
sapiens avant que la chaussure
rien n'arrête la détermination de la
chaman il faut continuer à monter et
leur peau se met à piquer leurs membres
se mettent à geler il voudrait
redescendre mais personne n'ose défier
nata la chamane décide pour le clan
chez sapiens le matriarcat est largement
répondu les femmes ont l'autorité elles
sont responsables de l'avenir du clan
les hommes suivent
le mieux vient de perdre son oreille
il n'y a Nissan ni douleur
que faire de son origine
comme on l'a rattacher le muet attend la
vie de la femme chaman
il n'y a rien à faire sauf peut-être la
manger
non le mieux préfère la manger lui-même
après tout c'est son oreille
[Musique]
un soleil nouveau s'est levé ce matin
mais ses premiers rayons n'apportent ni
chaleur ni nourriture en allant vers les
terres froides la peau de sapiens s'est
éclaircie afin de mieux capter les
rayons ultraviolets et de favoriser la
synthèse de vitamine essentielle
ils sont adaptés à une plus faible
exposition au soleil mais pas à la haute
montagne
durant son sommeil la première sœur de
nata est partie dans d'autres monde son
corps froid est devenu dur comme du bois
les croyances de sapiens sont aussi
nombreuses que les mystères de la nature
pour ce clan il n'y a pas de sépulture
ils offrent le corps des défunts à la
lumière
elle les mange et les emmène vers le
pays de l'autre vie
nata accompagne les morts pour les aider
à trouver le chemin un jour elle
retrouvera sa soeur dans le monde des
soleils
[Musique]
ils continuent d'avancer ils n'ont mangé
que de la neige depuis trois jours
a promis qu'au bout du chemin la nuit
n'existait plus et cela leur donne du
courage mais le courage ne nourrit pas
les plus faibles
tout le monde n'a pas droit à une
cérémonie certains sont abandonnés sans
rythme
qui prouve sa sœur elle ressent la
souffrance de son clan mais ils ne
peuvent pas s'arrêter
comment ont-ils fait pour résister et
leurs habits en pot ou la graisse
animale dont il s'enduisait le corps la
conquête des terres vierges se paye au
prix fort
sur le chemin sapiens laisse beaucoup
des siens
[Musique]
mais tous ces territoires explorés
profiteront au prochaines générations
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ils sont désormais moins que les doigts
d'une main
alors que leur force les abandonnent
l'espoir René
trois formes recouvertes de neige
certainement des animaux
de la nourriture pour retrouver des
forces et aller jusqu'au bout du voyage
ils sont sauvés
des pierres
plusieurs pierres
que font ces pierres sur des animaux
une aile d'oiseau
mais elle n'a pas de chair
d'autres hommes sont venus avant mais
qui sont-ils et d'où viennent-ils
pourquoi ces corps emprisonnés sous la
pierre
leur crâne ne ressemble pas aux autres
Nathalie
le pays des soleils n'est pas ici il n'y
a rien à manger ils sont condamnés
dans cet enfer personne ne peut survivre
personne sauf peut-être un être
exceptionnel
[Musique]
dans cette Europe froide et au style une
autre espèce humaine c'est parfaitement
adaptée au milieu l'homme de Néandertal
ils ont ouvert les tombes de leurs
ancêtres
Néandertal et lui aussi un descendant
d'Homo erectus
son ancêtre est arrivé en Europe il y a
2 millions d'années mais c'est d'adapter
au froid qui s'installait et est devenu
une force de la nature
le chef Néandertal a décidé de ramener
les étrangers au camp
ouvre les yeux
elle ne sait plus si elle est dans le
monde des vivants
quels sont ces gens qui ne sont pas tout
à fait désormais
sans jamais avoir été en contact avec
sapiens mais endertale aussi fait de son
côté de nombreuses découvertes le monde
invisible les croyances la musique le
feu il vit dans des cavernes et enterre
ses morts
Nathalie les siens ont été recueillis
par le clan de la lune
leur chef veut savoir qui a osé déterrer
ses ancêtres
le visage de Natal intrigue qui sont ses
êtres au front plat il faut qu'il
revienne à la vie
celui qui mène le clan de la lune veut
tout savoir sur eux
[Musique]
la chamane reprend parfois conscience
mais ce qu'elle découvre si étrange et
différent de tout ce qu'elle sait
que font-ils de son compagnon
ne peuvent pas faire ça il doit rester
avec elle elle a besoin de lui
différence de culture de langage de mode
de vie
pour ses sapiens les cultes de
Néandertal sont des sacrilège pourtant
sa culture n'est pas moins riche ni
moins belle
le lendemain l'odeur de la viande
grillée réveille nata et sa soeur
la fin est plus forte que tout
depuis la neige elles ont tout oublié
sous son tel qui les amenaient ici
peu à peu les images de ces hommes au
gros nez reviennent peupler les pensées
de nata
les souvenirs de son périple repassent
ce n'était pas un rêve
et ça me quai où est-il
nata se souvient maintenant de l'endroit
où ils ont enfermé son compagnon
elle ne sait pas ce qu'est une tombe
[Musique]
ils l'ont caché comme un gibier qu'on
garde pour plus tard comme les
squelettes dans la neige
[Musique]
elle doit le rendre à la lumière pour
que son esprit puisse partir avec le
vent des montagnes
pour survivre pendant la froidure de
l'hiver
Néandertal se nourrit principalement de
viande il est le plus grand chasseur de
la planète
en rentrant à la caverne une surprise
attend le chef
le mort enterré la veille et parti
il a fui
il est peut-être entré dans la terre
quelle est cette voix étrange
[Musique]
était là et la femme criait
le chef Néandertal ne comprend pas la
transe de Nathan
mais il est surpris par les mouvements
de son corps
Nathalie sa sœur resteront avec le clan
de la lune
[Musique]
sans le savoir c'est sapiens seront
découvert un nouveau continent l'Europe
cette traversée des Alpes a ouvert la
route et d'autres suivront bientôt les
traces de ces pionniers
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cette rencontre n'est que la première
d'autres suivront dans quelques
millénaires sapiens est Néandertal
vivront ensemble une aventure
exceptionnelle celle de la grande chasse
au même moment de l'autre côté de la
planète Homo sapiens se découvre l'Asie
avec la glaciation le niveau des océans
est alors 120 mètres plus bas
qu'aujourd'hui les îles d'Asie du
Sud-Est sont reliées entre elles Homo
sapiens va pousser son voyage jusqu'à la
limite des terres
[Musique]
au cours de ces migrations sapiens a
changé d'apparence les climats et les
environnements ont modifié la forme de
ses yeux de son nez et la couleur de sa
peau il a aussi découvert un nouveau et
fabuleux moyen pour se déplacer
la navigation
depuis des générations le plan de la
rivière a fait des fleuves le centre de
sa vie pour eux l'eau est sacrée elle
est la direction qu'il suive et les
protège contre les dangers voilà des
mois qui descendent ce cours d'eau ils
ont traversé la péninsule indonésienne
sans avoir croisé un seul clan
pourtant un autre humain est déjà là
depuis longtemps et il observe chacun de
leurs gestes
[Musique]
et lui aussi indécendant d'Homo erectus
arrivé ici il y a presque 2 millions
d'années il a évolué en plusieurs
sous-espèces qui peuplent toute l'Asie
homme de Pékin homme de Java ou homme de
Floreffe
chacun d'entre eux est adapté à son
milieu
le jeune et le seul à l'avoir vu et
personne ne veut le croire
le Clan de la Rivière ne s'arrête jamais
de naviguer
ils suivent le sens de l'eau se laisse
porter par les courants de cette veine
qui devient chaque jour plus large
[Musique]
il y a 60000 ans le Clan de la Rivière
arrive au bout des terres d'asile et
découvre l'océan Pacifique pour la
première fois
pour eux c'était tendu d'eau est un
nouveau fleuve dont on ne voit pas
l'autre rive
[Musique]
ils n'ont jamais vu ça ils sont fascinés
par ces vague immense par ce son qui
fait trembler leur corps
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le chef est déterminé à trouver le
chemin jusqu'au bout de l'eau il a
décidé de partager le clan en deux
groupes il part avec son chaman et sa
famille et reviendra ensuite chercher le
reste du clan
Homo sapiens ne s'est pas encore qu'en
face de lui des milliers de kilomètres
d'eau profonde sont prêtes à l'engloutir
emporté par sa foi ce petit groupe
d'hommes et de femmes s'élance à la
conquête d'un océan dont ils ignorent
toute la monstruosité
ce qui reste ont installé leur campement
trois femmes et un enfant protégés par
un seul guerrier
œil de serpent le plus habile pêcheur du
clan
depuis leur installation l'homme curieux
est venu plusieurs fois toujours le même
et il fait toujours la même chose
[Musique]
de serpent veut le rencontrer
il sait qu'il faut toujours apprivoiser
ceux qui viennent d'ailleurs pour éviter
qu'il ne devienne mauvais ou dangereux
l'homme repart toujours son attitude est
incompréhensible
cette fois-ci avec de serpent a décidé
d'agir différemment
il sait qu'aucun homme n'a réussi à le
prendre des vitesses
dans cette jungle asiatique il sait lire
tous les signaux décrypter les cris des
animaux et localiser n'importe quelle
créature à distance
[Musique]
il est là tout près que veut dire
avec des serpents c'est fait capturer
comme un buffle aveugle
sont en réalité de formidable chasseurs
leur règle pour la survie dans un milieu
tellement hostile préconise que tout
être vivant et mangeable même les
humains
dans certaines circonstances
l'ont capturé comme ils auraient pris un
bel oiseau pour l'instant il regarde ses
plus mais c'est couleur il invite à
partager leur repas
mais de quels sont
après cela le tuer le manger à son tour
œil de serpent doit rester calme
ce qui navigue vers l'autre rive ont
vite été emporté les vents et les
courants les éloignent de toute terre
quand ils se réveillent ce matin-là il
n'y a plus aucune rive ni d'un côté ni
de l'autre
il n'y a plus un seul oiseau dans le
ciel
[Musique]
le monde a disparu le fleuve géant a
tout recouvert
il dérive lentement vers l'Antarctique
ils sont sauvés
ils veulent en savoir plus sur les
secrets de ces hommes peints qui
marchent sur l'eau sur le pouvoir de
leur coquillages et de leurs hameçons
le chef du clan n'est toujours pas
revenu que faire s'il ne rentre pas
[Musique]
affaibli par le manque d'eau le chaman
vient de mourir
ses croyances se sont effondrées
souvent face à la violence de la nature
Homo sapiens doute de la raison de son
existence
ce qui marche sur l'eau commence à
échanger leur savoir avec ceux de la
forêt l'art de la parure les techniques
de pêche la fabrication des outils et
des habits
des liens se forment entre ces deux
populations pourtant si éloigner
génétiquement il est probable que
partout sur le continent asiatique
sapiens et erectus se soient mélangés
pour former ensemble la grande famille
des peuples d'Asie
à des centaines de kilomètres les
navigateurs sont à bout de force
déshydratées et brûlés par le soleil
la terre
l'autre côté du grand fleuve
le monde est revenu
il est remonté des profondeurs
[Musique]
ils ont navigué pendant des jours et des
jours grâce au courant alors
inconscience et le rodace ils arrivaient
puiser sur une terre que l'homme n'a
jamais foulé
peut-être croient-il avoir atteint le
monde secret de leur rêve
[Musique]
il y a 60 000 ans Homo sapiens
découvrent l'Australie une terre immense
détachée du reste du monde depuis des
millions d'années le berceau d'espèces
animales et végétales unique
[Musique]
il navigue encore de nombreuses fois sur
l'océan sans jamais retrouver leur
chemin ils seront à l'origine d'une
autre grande famille humaine un peuple
d'extraordinaire navigateur la famille
du Pacifique
dans le reste de l'Asie l'immigrations
continuent Homo sapiens traverse la
Chine et passe en Amérique à pied par le
détroit de Béring il découvre un autre
nouveau continent vaste et riche en
gibier il pousse son chemin jusqu'en
Amérique du Sud
pendant ce temps sapiens entre en Europe
par vague successives il s'adapte au
froid et à la vie classique dans le
toundra nous sommes à moins de 40 000
ans
l'hiver européen est terrible balayé par
les vents glaciales la seule nourriture
pour l'homme et la viande mais les
troupeaux ne sont pas toujours au
rendez-vous parfois même ils
disparaissent et la famine s'installe
sapiens se déplacer campement toujours
plus loin en espérant trouver du gibier
il vit dans des tipis et de peau et de
branches qu'il plante au sommet des
collines pour guetter le moindre animal
dans ces moments de carence les femmes
n'ont même plus de lait pour nourrir
leurs enfants et il meurt les uns après
les autres
le chef du clan des reines a trouvé
qu'un malheureux lapin mort de froid
ce n'est pas avec ça qu'il va nourrir
ses deux femmes et son clan
le clan des reines est en train de
devenir le clan du silence
[Musique]
inlassablement à qui a le chef parcourt
les alentours à la recherche du moindre
mouvement dans les buissons du moindre
cri animal
même la chair dure et puante de l'oiseau
noir est une aubaine avec sa nouvelle
arme le propulseur il ne rate jamais une
cible à cette distance
[Musique]
il veut savoir qui elle est et pourquoi
elle se trouve là la femme de comprends
pas
elle veut son collier
des yeux
comme si elle s'était connue
cette femme fait partie du peuple
Néandertal eux aussi souffre du manque
de gibier elle semble apprécier les
coquillages du collier de sapiens elle
n'a jamais vu ça
mais il est pris tout entier par son
désir de la toucher de la sentir
et maintenant il veut s'en parler d'elle
[Musique]
j'ai jamais une femme de lui a résisté
de la sorte lui a le chef du clan des
rêves
au petit matin des cris d'animaux
retenti près du campement
décrit comme ils n'en n'ont jamais
entendu et là devant eux descendants du
Nord des animaux énormes couvert de
longs poils et armés dedans immense
ce sont des longs
troupeaux ils avaient disparu
cette viande si proche et comment faire
pour les tuer
on sait que les chats non non le vieux
fou est prêt à les affronter mais cela
ne rassure pas le chef
le chemin ne trouve toujours les mots il
faut revenir l'esprit des ancêtres et
donnera la force aux chasseur à qui a
vaincra le chaman le sait
les mammouths occupent la terre depuis
des millions d'années pour ses
pachyderme comme pour les hommes la
nouvelle glaciation est un fléau
inlassablement ses grands animaux
parcours des distances énormes pour
trouver les 200 kilos de fourrage dont
ils ont besoin chaque jour
le chaman reste au sommet de la montagne
il parle aux gens invisibles
pris de nos ancêtres donner courage et
forts à nos chasseurs et tuer pour nous
ces géants
à qui à cette tuer le règne le cerf le
cochon mais jamais il n'ose et
s'attaquer à Paris une puissance
[Musique]
face à ces monstres ils ne sont rien la
peur fait battre les cœurs mais leur
estomac gris et l'odeur de cette viande
toute proche fait saliver leur bouche et
courir leurs jambes
[Musique]
trop rapide les longs nés se méfient de
l'homme ils le fuient
[Musique]
il le fuient jusqu'au moment où il se
retrouve bloqué contraint de se
retourner et sans outre solution que de
l'affronter et là leur peur les rend
encore plus dangereux
[Musique]
sauf l'un d'entre eux plus jeunes et
effrayé par les crises humains il ne
veut pas revenir sur ses pas
maintenant le combat devient inévitable
[Musique]
ils ont perdu la chasse et l'un d'entre
eux a perdu le souffle mais il y a
encore un espoir là-bas un groupe de
Néandertal ils sont aussi venus pour
tuer ils ont un avantage sur ceux du
clan des rênes ils connaissent le
pouvoir du feu sur les longs nez
[Musique]
de l'autre côté la femme Néandertal
effraie le dernier mammouth il doit
rebrousser chemin il y a encore une
chance une dernière
[Musique]
ne sont rien contre la dureté de la peau
de l'animal mais ils n'ont pas le choix
[Musique]
le jeune mammouth fonce maintenant vers
la sortie mais Néandertal est là
qu'il peut affronter la paix quand elle
est isolée mais c'est possible que ça ne
suffit pas il faut lui couper toute
retraite
mais on dit le plus grand des chasseurs
les Amal mystérieux ronge son corps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le long nez est bloqué pour la première
fois
sapiens est Néandertal se retrouve unie
autour d'une même proie poussée par le
même instinct de surplus ensemble ces
hommes et ses femmes fermaient toutes
retraites aux géants
il faut l'empêcher de bouger et
restreindre son espace au minimum la
femme Néandertal n'est plus en
compétition avec l'homme sapiens
[Musique]
ça y est il est à la merci des Lens il
faut frapper dans les endroits les plus
vulnérables l'aine et l'anus ou la peau
est moins épaisse
[Musique]
le chemin ne remerciera les ancêtres
jusqu'à la nuit grâce à eux le clan des
reines vient d'inventer une nouvelle
façon de chasser la grande chasse
organisée et cette nouveauté va avoir
des conséquences considérables sur la
vie des hommes
avec la viande du mammouth les deux
clans de la nourriture comme il n'en ont
jamais eu ils peuvent rester des mois
sans chasser pour la première fois les
hommes ont du temps devant eux du temps
libre pour penser expérimenter et faire
des choses apparemment
inutiles
[Rires]
Néandertal et sapiens se retrouvent
ensemble autour d'un repas avec de
nouveaux sentiments ceux de l'entraide
de la solidarité
et aussi de l'attirance
[Musique]
la femme Néandertal veut le chef du clan
des reines pour elle mais à qui a déjà
de compagnes et rien ne se fera sans
l'accord de ses fans
elles sont d'accord
elles vivront ensemble
de l'autre et cela passera par un long
apprentissage du langage petit à petit
mot parent
la découverte de la coopération pour les
grandes chasses prépare un mouvement
inéluctable de rapprochement entre les
hommes de différentes origines bientôt
des liens nouveaux vont voir le jour
mariage alliance
les racines de la société
ce soir à qui elle veut prendre celle
qui le rend fort et heureux
quel est ce mal qui fait saigner son nez
la femme Néandertal souffre mais il se
plaisent et ils veulent mieux se
connaître
[Musique]
c'est alliance ne plaît pas au chaman il
se méfie de la femme Néandertal
cette femme et c'est Tom appartiennent
tous deux aujourd'hui mais ils ne sont
pas de la même espèce
leur union ne peut donner de descendance
ils sont génétiquement différents
l'esprit de la femme a volé celui de son
chef
il faut protéger le clan des reines et
communiquer avec la pensée d'Akira
ce soir là le feu projette l'ombre du
chapeau du chef sur le rocher
pour le chaman c'est la partie animale
qui est dans le chef et elle danse sur
la pierre
il la voit
il veut garder le souvenir de ce moment
magique alors il en suit les contours
avec du charbon de bois
l'esprit est là
reste sur la pierre
il l'a repris à la fin
il y a 40000 ans la première
représentation symbolique est fixée sur
de la pierre la naissance de l'art c'est
invention aura bientôt une portée
universelle
[Musique]
quelques années ont passé les deux clans
ont fait route ensemble mais presque
tous les Néandertal sont morts du mal
qui les affectent tous
ils ne sont plus que trois dans la femme
du chef
[Musique]
elle n'en peut plus elle doit rester là
c'est la fin du voyage
[Musique]
aucun enfant n'est venu de son ventre
le clan ne peut s'arrêter l'hiver
l'étalonnes il faut marcher vers le sud
[Musique]
celui qui marche devant et il doit se
conduire comme tel pensez avant tout à
l'avenir du clan des reines
épuisé par les fièvres la femme veut se
reposer et refroidir son corps dans
l'eau glacée
[Musique]
les humains de cette espèce on peut un
peu disparaître de la terre
fauchée par les maladies par une
réduction des naissances
cela reste encore un mystère
[Musique]
à qui elle ne veut plus entendre les
prières du chaman
peut-être ce doute t-il de la fragilité
de notre espèce
[Musique]
Néandertal disparaît la chasse aux
grands mammifères se répand sur toute la
planète le rythme de vie change plus de
temps libre plus de création Homo
sapiens sculpte ses objets fabrique des
parures et des corps ses outils une
véritable explosion culturelle dans
certains endroits une création humaine
surpuissante va voir le jour
l'art pariétal l'art va devenir un
message
nous sommes en France il y a 20 000 ans
Homo sapiens s'est dispersé dans toute
l'Europe
parfois il souffre d'isolement certains
clans ne trouvent pas d'autres
populations avec lesquelles se mélanger
ils se reproduisent entre eux sur une
deux trois générations
inévitablement la consanguinité frappe
leurs enfants les rendent incapables de
se reproduire à leur tour et d'assurer
l'avenir du clan
vous la des années que adka le sorcier
cherche à guérir les siens de cette
malédiction
[Musique]
mais l'ancêtre qu'il est guide reste
muet il ne répond plus
[Musique]
adka a-t-il perdu son pouvoir
il aurait
sorcier s'il n'est pas capable de
soigner son clan
adka se sent seul isoler du reste du
groupe avec son fils sur les bras
[Musique]
autrefois le clan des chasseurs de
bisons était prospère il y avait huit
chasseurs 12 femmes de nombreux enfants
aujourd'hui ne sont plus que 9 et un
seul enfant mal
s'il ne trouve pas rapidement une
solution le clan disparaîtra
[Musique]
le chef vient de découvrir un abri pour
l'hiver
le fils d'adka est agité comme si ce
lieu lui parlait comme s'il entendait
des voix
[Musique]
la caverne est accueillante spacieuse
proche de l'eau et abritée du vent
elle a la forme d'un crâne
des feux ont été allumés ici
il a des gens endormi
des gens ont mangé
d'autres ont vécu ici à volonté
[Musique]
où sont-ils à présent
l'enfant était le premier à repérer le
passage
[Musique]
il cherchait toujours à se cacher pour
être en dehors du monde
qui se cache au fond du ventre de la
caverne des ours des lions
ou des humains
[Musique]
les grottes sont les meilleures endroits
pour les rituels chamaniques
[Musique]
mais ils sont autre chose là juste à
côté de lui
des signes fait par la main de l'homme
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les premiers ornements rupestres il
figure des stries des cercles des
spirales
ces formes sont les visions d'un chaman
dans le premier stade de sa trans
hallucinatoire
ils étaient là d'autres mains d'hommes
ont gravé cette roche
que s'est-il passé ici
ont-ils voulu laisser un message
[Musique]
à te casser prendre les forces cachées
dans les racines les insectes et les
mollusques il en fait des couleurs pour
sa peinture et des potions pour soigner
grâce à eux il pourra retrouver l'esprit
Guéret de son fils
il veut le ramener à côté de lui dans le
monde du visible
[Musique]
cette limace donne la vision
elle permet d'atteindre les profondeurs
de l'âme et de voyager dans la visite
là où se cache l'esprit de son enfant
[Musique]
son ancêtre sorcier lui avait tout
appris en retournant à la nature il y a
bien longtemps
il était devenu bison mais son esprit
guidé toujours à cœur
adka fait appel à la force de l'animal
lui demande de l'aider pour guérir son
enfant
[Musique]
elle est spécialement efficace
l'esprit malade de l'enfant résiste
il ne veut pas se laisser attraper il
fuit adka le sud pas à pas il ne le
laissera pas s'échapper
au dessus de la transe le clan s'est
installé pour le repas ce qu'ils
attendent depuis des années est en train
d'arriver
les hommes et des femmes d'un autre clan
il ne parle pas la même langue il faut
accueillir ceux qui viennent d'ailleurs
la chance est avec nous
ils ne veulent pas d'un autre clan ici
ils ne veulent pas partager
alors que les bras vont frapper l'esprit
du bison s'empare du corps d'adka
[Rires]
[Musique]
bagarre
cette femme porte les signes des
sorciers
et là tout de suite entendu les appels
data dans les profondeurs du crâne en
pierre
[Musique]
son corps ne lui appartient plus ces
mouvements sont ceux de l'animal
la sorcière la comprit et l'antre dans
cette Rance
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la main le contour d'une nouvelle image
devant les yeux des étrangers les hommes
des deux clans sont pris par le
spectacle il cessent de se battre et
attendre la suite
[Musique]
l'image compte une forme qu'il connaisse
elle le rappelle une émotion qu'ils ont
déjà vécu ils se regardent ils
ressentent la même chose et cela leur va
droit dans le cœur
[Musique]
transforme est-ce grâce à la lueur des
flammes ou à la danse du sorcier
il voit tous l'esprit de l'animal il
avance il marche il l'entend même ils
vivent ensemble intérieur de l'âme
humaine
[Musique]
la peinture des cavernes devient un
langage qui va permettre à tous les Homo
sapiens de se comprendre et de
s'accepter elle sera un message
universel qui touche le cœur des hommes
et les rendent tous solidaires
[Musique]
il s'entraide ils échangent leur savoir
ils trouvent une meilleure façon de se
protéger des vents glaciales
il prépare ensemble l'arrivée de l'hiver
adka n'a pas pu retrouver l'esprit perdu
de l'enfant pas encore
les deux sorciers échangent leurs
secrets sur les plantes médicinales à
deux ils deviennent deux fois plus
savants ils commencent la grande
collègue des mystères de la nature de ce
savoir immense naîtra un jour la
médecine
entre -30 000 et - 20 000 ans des
chefs-d'œuvre apparaissent presque sur
toute la planète à des milliers de
kilomètres les uns des autres
comme si tous les Homo sapiens s'étaient
donné le mot partout l'art rassemble des
petits groupes d'hommes et les FEDER en
communauté plus vaste
bientôt des populations immenses vont
s'unifier pour devenir des peuples
les continents prennent peu à peu les
formes qu'on leur connaît aujourd'hui
une époque grandiose de la vie des
hommes s'achève mais une nouvelle
commande
presque partout la température devient
Clémence l'eau abondance et la terre
généreuse sapiens découvre des régions
tellement riches en gibier en plan de
comestibles qu'il s'arrête de marcher
il construit des villages de pierres
fait pour durer c'est pour beaucoup la
fin d'une vie de nomade qui remonte à
toujours avec la sédentarisation tout va
changer
[Musique]
nous sommes en Mésopotamie il y a 10 ans
écoute mon histoire
elle a bouleversé la vie des hommes
alors
les nôtres ne connaissaient pas encore
tout ce que l'on sait aujourd'hui
[Musique]
était un homme apprécié de tous les
particulièrement de ma mère il
s'arrêtait pour la voir quand il
rentrait de la chasse et lui apporter
toujours des œufs d'oiseaux
[Musique]
depuis quelques temps la vie était
devenue moins dure pour les hommes et
les femmes et il commençait à prendre du
temps pour être heureux ensemble
[Musique]
de ma mère
[Rires]
[Musique]
il ne cachait pas leur affection à la
vie de tous même si sa musait tout le
monde et surtout le chef du village
ils étaient heureux et un souci
[Musique]
ce jour-là pourtant elle avait tué un
pressentiment
[Musique]
en ce temps-là nous devions aller loin
dans la montagne pour cueillir les
blesses qu'il poussait c'était la fin de
l'été et l'on devait ramasser le plus de
grains possible pour passer l'hiver sans
manquer
[Musique]
savait quand cette saison le faucon
pondait ses œufs ma mère aimait
tellement les yeux
cet homme il y a 10 000 ans connaît
parfaitement la nature elle ne le fait
plus souffrir elle est pleine de
surprises merveilleuses et il commence à
jouer avec elle
[Musique]
elle ne l'a pas vu partir
elle croit qu'il est en train de lui
jouer un tour
[Musique]
elle se souvient de son pressentiment
joue avec la nature
mais parfois quand il va trop loin la
nature refuse de jouer
[Musique]
la montagne avalé le corps de Néné
tout ma mère le cherche
en vainqueur
[Musique]
jusqu'au moment où ils entendent le cri
du loup
ils prennent peur pour nénés
mieux va les rester ensemble si les
loups étaient nombreux on craignait les
loups
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un homme qui gémit
elles sont que nénés et là tout proche
d'elle
[Musique]
ce n'est pas né mais le plus étrange
spectacle qui lui était donné de voir un
petit homme avec une louve des montagnes
le plus féroce des carnassiers
les loups étaient à côté de nous depuis
toujours quand nos enfants se perdaient
dans la forêt les loups les dévorés
nous n'aimions pas les loups surtout
notre chef il en avait tué plus d'un
[Musique]
mais il n'a pas le temps de s'occuper de
celui-là
il entend à son tour les gémissements de
l'enfant
est farouche certainement abandonné par
un autre clan
[Musique]
ma mère veut le réconforter mais il
refuse
[Musique]
le chef on a vu d'autres et ce n'est pas
cet enfant qui va changer l'ordre des
choses
occupé par le sort de l'enfant il cesse
de chercher Néné
de toute manière s'il était par là il
leur répondra
Homo sapiens vit ici dans de petites
huttes de pierres rassemblées autour
d'un grenier commun le premier village
les premières maisons
ma mère a pris l'enfant avec elle et
l'installer sur la couche de Néné
mais l'enfant ne veut pas dormir
[Musique]
il écoute la montagne
elle ne pouvait pas croire que la louve
était la mère de l'enfant
sa mère animale
on avait encore jamais vu ça
[Musique]
ma mère avait beaucoup d'amour à donner
peut-être trop pour une toute seule
[Musique]
j'étais cet enfant sauvage je ne me
sentais pas homme je me prenais pour un
loup
de retour
dans ce premier village
Homo sapiens se partagent les tâches
chacun travaille pour la communauté les
peaux servent maintenant de récipient
les pierres chauffées au feu font
bouillir les marmites
les femmes pensent aux hommes
il n'y a plus vraiment de clan mais
plusieurs familles et chaque famille à
son foyer on se rend service on se rend
visible la polygamie a tendance à
disparaître la famille se resserre
autour du couple un homme et une femme
leurs enfants et parfois leurs parents
la famille d'aujourd'hui est en train de
naître et celle dont rêvé ma mère vient
de disparaître
aucune trace de néon personne ne l'a vu
personne ne l'a entendu
ma mère avait besoin d'aimer besoin de
donner elle ne pouvait rester seule sans
partager sa vie
[Musique]
je ne voulais personne près de moi je ne
supportais pas compte ni le contact et
l'odeur des habits
[Musique]
je n'accepte que sa présence
mais pas la viande noire de feu qu'elle
voulait me faire manger
à l'enfant sauvage elle s'attache à moi
j'étais en train de prendre une place
dans son cœur
la place d'un fils
[Musique]
la louve est revenue un beau jour pour
réclamer son fils
[Musique]
elle m'avait nourri
protégée
réchauffé depuis que j'étais un
nouveau-né
[Musique]
les hommes n'aiment pas les loups parce
qu'ils ne les connaissent pas jamais ma
mère louve ne m'aurait fait de mal
pourtant les hommes me croyaient en
danger avec elle comme le sont tous les
enfants avec tous les loups
[Musique]
elle a été la première à comprendre
peut-être parce qu'elle ressentait
l'amour de l'animal
parce qu'elle souffrait elle aussi de
l'absence de celui qu'elle avait aimé
et je ne savais pas laquelle choisir
[Musique]
elle a su parler au loup comme un enfant
voilà comment ma mère est devenue ma
mère pour toute la vie
[Musique]
une année à passer j'ai grandi dans le
monde des hommes la loupérité près du
village et petit à petit elle s'est
habituée à la présence des hommes
une alliance est née entre l'homme et
l'animal et ça a été le début d'une
grande aventure avec les loups mais
aussi avec d'autres animaux
il y a 12000 ans le premier loup rejoint
la communauté des hommes mais il faudra
des générations de loups nés chez les
hommes pour qu'ils deviennent ce que
nous appelons aujourd'hui le chien
[Musique]
grâce à ma mère louve nous avons fait
d'autres découvertes
un corps mort depuis longtemps je disais
au milieu des blesses
c'était la dépouille de Néné
[Musique]
il avait disparu le jour où ma mère
m'avait trouvé elle m'avait donné
l'amour qu'elle avait pour lui
[Musique]
c'était son collier
ma mère a tout de suite su ce qu'elle
devait en faire
[Musique]
les grains de blé qui étaient dans la
besace de Néné avait germé
là où ils étaient tombés ils avaient
poussé
[Musique]
le chef compris que chaque grain s'était
reproduit en une multitude d'autres
c'était si simple et pour ton personne
n'y avait jamais pensé
ma mère m'a donné le collier de Néné
et j'ai grandi toute ma vie avec jusqu'à
aujourd'hui
ce collier te revient désormais
à toi le fils de mon fils
porte le et transmets le à ceux qui
viendront après toi
raconte cette histoire à tous les hommes
afin qu'ils ne l'oublie jamais
[Musique]
nous sommes il y a 10 000 ans
grâce à ces deux fabuleuses découvertes
la vie des hommes va basculer
[Musique]
la découverte de l'agriculture se
propage alors sur toute la terre en
quelques siècles Homo sapiens s'installe
durablement à proximité de ses cultures
il calque sa vie sur les rythmes des
saisons récoltant chaque année le fruit
de son travail
[Musique]
la domestication du loup est suivie par
celle de nombreux autres animaux
Homo sapiens découvrent l'élevage qui
procure une alimentation sur et
abondante
[Musique]
dans de nombreux endroits du monde des
monuments gigantesques se dressent vers
les cieux
en hommage aux divinités dont sapiens se
dit le fils
les hommes se multiplient les villages
se construisent les échanges
s'intensifient des groupes de plus en
plus vastes de ce constitue bientôt des
grandes civilisations vont voir le jour
la préhistoire est finie
[Musique]
quel que soit la couleur de notre peau
quel que soit la forme de nos yeux les 6
milliards d'êtres humains qui peuplent
notre terre aujourd'hui descendent tous
d'une même famille
et la vécu dans la nuit des temps et en
centra des milliers de générations
d'hommes et de femmes jusqu'à nous
leur découverte éclaire toujours nos
vies
tel est le temps que nos parents aussi
lointain soit-il nous ont fait
grâce à eux nos enfants irons peuplés
d'autres planètes
[Musique]